[Music]
on this Thursday night top secret
documents confirm foreign interference
what Canadian security agencies believe
happened during two Federal elections
the culprits the scope of the meddling
and the safeguards needed to protect
democracy putting limits on transgender
rights they are going to cause
irreparable harm the Alberta Premier
sweeping new rules igniting anger
waiting to die with dignity I don't
understand why it's taking so long those
living with dementia still waiting for
the right to a medically assisted death
and a sour note you
go why Tik Tok has just lost millions of
[Music]
songsone global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us Global News has new details
from a top secret briefing about foreign
interference in Canada information that
confirms our months of reporting on this
we obtained the CEUs briefing through
access to information it was written in
February of 2023 and is heavily redacted
but reveals cus knew that the PRC the
People's Republic of China sought to
clandestinely and deceptively influence
the 2019 and 2021 Federal elections it
calls China by far the most significant
threat but also names India David Aken
digs into the detail and why the top
secret report predicts the problem will
get worse me before we jump in no one
has suggested that the trudo Liberals
won the last two elections because of
foreign interference but cus is certain
foreign interference happened and China
was the chief culprit as recent as just
a few months ago um there still has
been um attacked uh using my name um and
labeling me as as anti-chinese hater of
China good to have you guys Kenny Chu
Won in the 2019 federal election but
lost in 2021 democracy Freedom after
advocating for a foreign agent registry
something that could have targeted
Canadian operatives of the communist
government of China I feel not only
exposed um but there's a a level of
sense of betrayal by my country the
People's Republic of China's foreign
interference activities are Broad in
scope and significant in the level of
expended resources a cist analyst wrote
the activities are sophisticated
pervasive persistent and directed
against all levels of government and
Civil Society across the country cus
warns more must be done to guard against
foreign interference not just in the
next federal election but also Municipal
and provincial elections like the one to
be held this fall in British Columbia
the documents obtained by global news
are heavily redacted government sensors
blacking out entire portions on the
grounds that they are shielding top
secret information about China's
attempts to interfere in elections as
well as attempts by India to interfere
in Canadian
politics at the foreign interference
inquiry Thursday cus boss David Vigo
defended the censors who blacked out
those sections the purpose of cus is to
have
secrets which is different than
transparency the inquiry though wants to
lift those redactions to put what cus
and others know about foreign
interference on the public record Vigo
says there may be ways to do that so if
you're talking foreign interference by
country X you could have a a CIS
intelligence report that would be
completely blacked
out and you could also have a a document
that can be produced with the intent to
be released the whole point of the
inquiry of course is to increase or
perhaps even restore confidence that
Canadians have in their elections and as
the inquiry has heard several times this
week the only way to do that is with
increased transparency Donna David Aken
in Ottawa thanks David and you can find
out more about the top secret cus
briefing and our investigation into
foreign interference on our website
globalnews.ca
globalnation Alberta's Premier has
revealed more about her sweeping new
policy she calls parental rights and
Danielle Smith is taking lots of heat
for it it will require parental consent
for kids 15 years and younger to change
their names or pronouns at school and
for them to to take part in classes on
Sexual Health sexual orientation and
gender identity as well kids 15 and
younger will be banned from taking
puberty blockers and hormone therapies
Premier Smith says her ideas are rooted
in love critics say it sounds more like
oppression this is the right balance
this is what I believe Alberton expect
of us to do to make sure that we're
protecting kids choices this is uh an
issue that uh Danielle Smith is uh
pursuing uh because of extremist
politics not because there's a massive
uh call for it Daniel Smith has not
reasonably consulted with the people who
are most impacted by this Heather urick
West is following reaction to this
tonight for children who identify as
transgender I want you to also know that
these policies are being implemented in
order to protect the choices you have
regarding altering your physical body
Albert's Premier says sweeping policy
changes on gend identity are about
protecting kids but Luca Roger Duncan
isn't so sure at 25 he remembers very
well what it was like to be a
transgendered teen in her statement she
says we want these kids to know that
they're loved but in doing what she's
doing and in saying what she's saying
she's implying that that love is in fact
conditional Alberta is the third
Canadian province to introduce a policy
on parental rights when it comes to
gender identity Alberta Saskatchewan and
New Brunswick now require parental
consent for students under the age of 16
who want to change their name or
pronouns but Alberta has taken its
measures further Banning hormonal
treatment and puberty blockers for
children under 16 and prohibiting gender
reaffirming surgery for those 17 and
under I I certainly do not want um
children to be making decisions before
maybe they've even had sex but
Physicians who work with the transgender
Community say they were not consulted we
have guidelines we have science we have
everything backing up the decisions we
make so it's not a place of a premier or
political party to tell us what to do
medically the policy is not enforcable
until it becomes legislation when that
happens eal Canada plans to challenge
the new laws in court it's deeply
troubling that Alberta has taken this
decision because it amounts to an
attempt to erase gender diverse people
from society those applauding Alberta's
policy are calling it an important first
step the uh cult the insanity that's
been sweeping the culture with this
transgender ideology the theory of
gender identity the theory of gender
expression it's uh it's collapsing
before our eyes and and thank goodness
Roger Duncan has a different message for
transgender youth I would tell them that
it's scary and it's okay to feel sad and
angry and grieve he says he's proof that
transgender people exist have a voice
and that as a community that voice will
be heard and Heather's with me now
Heather Premier Smith says she doesn't
want to politicize this whole issue her
critics say that's exactly what she's
doing how much of this is pandering to
social conservatives who helped get her
elected yeah Donna you really can't
ignore how Danielle Smith became Premier
she claimed the party leadership after
appealing to the most socially
conservative faction of the UCP and was
then elected by sweeping the most
conservative uh rural uh rural ridings
so this was a legislation this was a
policy that was very popular at the
ucp's most recent AGM and given the
experience of Jason Kenny who lost party
support after angering those social
conservatives you can really see the
politics at play Donna all right Heather
Yurick Weston Calgary thanks now to
another sensitive policy the federal
government is punting a decision on
expanding medically assisted death for
people whose so medical condition is
mental illness until 2027 the government
has said Canada's Healthcare System is
not ready we've always had a delicate
balance in mind that is how do you
Empower autonomy and dignity on the part
of an individual and at the same time
ensure that vulnerable people are
protected and there is another
completely separate debate underway
about medically assisted dying that
involves Advanced consent and it has
considerable support across Canada it
would allow a competent person to
request made before they lose the
ability to consent it's something people
with Alzheimer's and Dementia have been
requesting a recent poll found 82% of
Canadians support made for those
suffering from a grievous illness with
no Prospect of improvement a committee
recommended moving forward with
legislation on Advanced consent last
year but it hasn't happened and as NE
through garer reports those living with
dementia are left waiting Dave there you
are with Rick Hansen meeting the pope we
love to hike bike ski scuba dive um and
travel the world Susan Arch says her
husband Dave was active outgoing healthy
and fit then about 10 years ago life
took a turn they couldn't have expected
Dave was diagnosed at the young age of
55 with early onset Alzheimer's
disease as she Wheels him in at the
North Vancouver BC Care Facility he now
calls home his cognitive decline is
clear there you go unable to feed
himself start with a milkshake and she
says over the last month he can no
longer recognize her the two criteria he
had written in his Advanced request for
medical assistance in dying also known
as maid what decision would you make
today given the developments of the last
month I would make the decision for maid
for
Dave I struggle a lot with that decision
I I lose a lot of sleep over it um but I
know that's what he wanted open a little
wider despite Quebec's legalization of
it in June and a parliamentary committee
recommending it Advan requests for
people diagnosed with debilitating
diseases like Alzheimer's have not been
approved by Ottawa I don't understand
why it's taking so long you think
they're doing it for political purposes
that's one LGE part of it Ron posno and
his wife are discussing the delay in
approving Advanced requests something
the dementia patient has long advocated
for my uh disease started likely with a
head accident that bosted the eye the
84-year-old says he's been given 3 years
to live I've laid out eight very
specific conditions as so when any one
of them occur that's the time I want
made thank you very much it's not so
easy to operationalize who will decide
when those parameters have been met uh
what exactly dictates when those
parameters have been met Dr Stephanie
Green has been administering maid since
it became legal in Canada in 2016 we see
more people asking for it we see more
people receiving it in a statement the
federal health Minister's office said
the issue is complex and significant
consultation and study is needed through
the painful weit There's Hope Dave finds
soulless in Susan's touch a moment of
Love through his fog of fading memories
neua Global News North Vancouver
BC a day after recommendations were made
at the inquest into the 2022 Mass
stabbings at the James Smith Cree Nation
indigenous leaders are calling for
action the James Smith creation tragedy
uh shows a as a as a prime example of
how the lack of local First Nations
police and Justice Services added to the
vulnerabilities of First Nations the
leaders say the local coroners inquest
is not sufficient to investigate the
causes and consequences of the horrific
event they want a national inquiry five
former members of Canada's World Junior
Team have been told to appear in court
in London Ontario on Monday court
documents released today show Alex
formenton Cal foot Carter Hart Dylan
Dubay and Michael McLoud are each
charged with one count of sexual assault
McLoud also faces an additional charge
of sexual assault by being a party to
the offense they're accused of
assaulting a young woman in 2018 lawyers
for all five players say they intend to
plead not
guilty a matter of life and death coming
up what should be done to save more
people who go into cardiac
arrest
there's new insight into how many people
suffer from cardiac arrest in Canada
it's higher than previously thought the
Heart and Stroke Foundation says every
year 60,000 cardiac arrests happen
outside of hospital that's 20,000 more
than previous estimates suggested and of
those people just one in 10 survives
without CPR or life-saving equipment the
chances of surviving a cardiac arrest
Dro significantly and that's why as
Katherine Ward explains there are calls
for more awareness and
training Kim Ruther remembers May 2012
with absolute Clarity she was talking to
her son Brock an energetic and athletic
teenager he told me about an upcoming
volleyball practice I said you better
enjoy this practice Brock because if you
don't get your math mark up it'll be the
last practice you ever go to and I
remember he was really sad when he left
30 minutes later a call came that every
parent dreads Brock had
tripped or Fallen he' collapsed on the
floor in the gym and they didn't know
what was going on but he wasn't
breathing
normally and they were just calling 911
Brock suffered a cardiac arrest and died
an automatic external defibrillator was
available pull green tab to remove pads
but it wasn't used despite the
availability of the AED nobody was
trained to get
or recognize that this was a sudden
Cardiac Arrest emergency a cardiac
arrest means the heart has stopped
beating it can be a sudden event with
little to no warning with nearly half
happening to people under
65 people are essentially dead but they
are able to be resuscitated Advocates
say it's important people know where
aeds are kept and how to use them and
that workplaces ensure the devices are
easily accessible it will only shock a
heart
if that shock is needed and the Machine
will determine that so it's safe Denise
BAC From The Heart and Stroke Foundation
wants to see more training so people are
prepared for real life emergencies the
goal is to have all of our school
students trained creating a generation
of people who can help others Katherine
Ward Global News
Toronto cash injection ahead a financial
boost to help
Ukraine
[Music]
Ukraine's defense Ministry released this
footage today of what it says is a drone
attack that sank a $70 million Russian
warship off Crimea the night vision
video shows a small vessel approaching
the ship and then there's a large
explosion and the vessel sinks the area
has come under increasing attack from
Ukraine Crimea annexed by Russia in 2014
is home to its Black Sea
Fleet the EU has proven that its word
matters and its promises work for the
interests of entire
Europe Ukrainian President Vladimir
zalinsky thanked European leaders today
for giving his country a financial
Lifeline Europe will provide 54 billion
to support Ukraine's war against Russia
political infighting had been holding up
the funding and Hungary had threatened
to veto it Crystal ganing explains why
the money is so badly needed European
leaders from 27 nations with vastly
different priorities have shown up for
Ukraine we all know that Ukraine is
fighting for us so we will support them
with the necessary funding and provide
them with a much needed predictability
they deserve the block of Nations agreed
to send the equivalent of $54 billion us
to Ukraine over 4 years money to help
pay public sector workers pensions and
keep the lights
on Ukrainian officials say defending
against Russian invading Forces cost
more than $100
million per
day the new European Aid package is
needed but not nearly enough an American
Aid package worth $61 billion is
currently hung up in Congress
Republicans are stalling it as they
angle for policy changes on unrelated
immigration matters getting the EU
package over the line wasn't without its
challenges there's no problem with
so-called you you know Ukraine fatigue
for sure we have Orban fatigue now
Victor Orban the Hungarian prime
minister is the Russian president's
closest Ally in Europe late last year he
refused to approve the package it's a
sign of unity to the extent that there
was enough urgency within enough of uh
the European capitals that they felt
that they had to do this they had to
make him agree the last time a European
council meeting was held credibility of
Europe was at stake and we all together
strengthened that credibility
credibility in the form of financial aid
that will start flowing in March Crystal
Ganson Global News London the American
President Joe Biden signed an executive
order today targeting Israeli settlers
in the West Bank who have been attacking
Palestinians at authorizes Financial
sanctions and Visa bans against four
Israeli settlers involved in violence
against Palestinians including forced
displacement and destruction of their
property us officials are also
evaluating whether to punish others
involved in similar activities Biden
says the violence of settlers threatens
US foreign policy objectives and the
viability of a two-state
solution you girl but out of next why
Tik Tok is out of time with with
thousands of
[Music]
artists that's one of Taylor Swift's
hits that you won't hear on Tik Tok
anymore Universal Music Group has pulled
its catalog of music from the social
media platform after a licensing
agreement between the two expired at
issue is compensation for artists
protection from artificial intelligence
and Online safety Mike drle explains
what it means for the roughly 1 billion
Tik Tok users and for musicians
themselves the road to stardom was
anything but traditional for Calgary's
Tate
mccraig dancing to her own music she
uploaded videos to Tik
Tok which ultimately became a worldwide
viral trend she's absolutely somebody
that can take a look at social media and
say without that platform she might not
have a career as much as she does right
now but that music industry Tik Tok
marriage is on the Rocks Universal music
group is pulling its tracks from the
platform including Drake and Taylor
Swift I won't be able to promote my
music on Tik Tok anymore but luckily I'm
not a Tik Tok artist right I'll probably
be okay right I'll land on my feet right
it's significant because of how the
music industry has
changed an artist like Elvis for example
needed a label to record an album in a
studio it was
expensive but technology cut out the
studio when Mobi recorded an entire
album in his apartment using a laptop
computer and when YouTube social media
and streaming services came along it
allowed anybody the ability to
distribute and promote their own
product Universal posted an open letter
on why we must call timeout on Tik Tok
explaining they have three issues
compensation the harmful effects of AI
and Online safety for Tik tok's users
money is of course an
issue Snoop Dogg reported he made
$45,000 from over a billion streams on
Spotify and Tik Tok pays even less
roughly $ 20 to $40 for a million views
the real concern is AI which the music
industry fears will replace human
artists eventually so the two sides
could reconcile and if you want to reach
the Gen Z you have to be on Tik
Tok because like it or not that's where
all the cool kids are Mike dret Global
News Toronto that's what my son tells me
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna FZ and tonight's your
candada is stuck M nation in British
Columbia thanks for watching Neu garer
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow and
I will see you again on Monday
byebye
[Music]